nope I don't do high-fives it could
still be out there watching waiting
listen are you scrapbooking my plan
there will be no more scrapbooking
branch branch branch branch are you in
there I'm not going to your party yeah
the party's over we just got attacked by
a Bergen I knew it
brinch I Shh I have to tell you
something I Shh I was just gonna shish
she what what could be so important that
it's worth leading the Bergen right to
us the Bergen is gone you don't know
that it can still be out there watching
waiting listen which is why I have to
ask you will you go to Bergen town with
me and save everyone
what no bridge you can't say no they're
your friends ah they're your friends I'm
staying right here in my bunker where
it's safe
oh that's great you're the one guy who
knows more about burgins than anyone but
when we finally need you you just want
to hide in here forever forever no huh
you all said I was crazy huh
well who's crazy now me crazy prepared
I'm sorry I should have listened to you
you told me not to throw the party and I
threw it anyway it's my fault that they
were taken and now I don't know what to
do well thanks anyway hey any time poppy
see you 10 11 years oh hey branch I just
was just wondering if I could borrow
something what your bunker
what okay everybody come on in no no no
wait poppy what are you doing
you said you have enough provisions to
last ten years right yeah to last me ten
years me it'll blast them two weeks then
I guess it better hurry branch branch
branch branch are you in there
I'm not going to your party the party is
over we just got attacked
Bergin ah I knew it Grinch Shh I have to
tell you something I was just gonna say
she's just Josh what what could be so
important that it's worth leading the
Bergen right to us
the Birkins gone you don't know that it
could still be out there watching
waiting listen a know it left and it
took Cooper and smidge and fuzz Burt and
satin and chenille and Biggie and Guy
Dimond and Creek hey will you go to
Bergen town with me and save everyone
what no breeze you can't say no they're
your friends ah ah they're your friends
I'm staying right here in my bunker
where it's safe
oh that's great you're the one guy who
knows more about bergens than anyone but
when we finally need you you just want
to hide in here forever
Josh what I could be so important that
it's worth leading the Bergen wait - no
the Bergen is gone you don't know that
it could still be out there once upon a
time in a happy forest in the happiest
tree lived the happiest creatures the
world has ever known the trolls don't
worry no troll ever will be thanks to my
dad that's why we're celebrating with
the biggest party ever
everybody's gonna be there branch I know
you have happiness inside you you just
need our help to find it to leave before
the Perkins come back but Dad they're
our friends we have to rescue them
awesome don't worry dad I can do this I
love you puppy I love you too dad I
don't need no reason don't need control
and then we'll both sing I fly so high
don't see you then
I'm gonna lights when everything goes
nowhere to hide and I'm getting your
clothes it's like it's very ugly but it
for some reason it makes sense I think I
hear something
my father banished you 20 years ago okay
now it's like I wouldn't bring it down
huh [ __ ] where did you come from my
father banished you 20 years ago
I've even stayed behind that plate this
whole time what am I gonna do
i'ma bring back TRO stairs Oh looks good
real fancy all right oh wait a minute
chef this isn't enough whoops oh here we
go
remember your Chester Oh Justin
Timberlake is kind of doing kind of our
army guy instead of our intern
production assistant is that the good
stuff first
all right looks good real fancy wait a
minute chef this isn't enough trolls to
feel Berk until this looks like a snack
pack
oh no no no there's plenty more where
that came from side don't you worry
no no no no no justice is ruined we'll
never be happy never Oh Barnabas you're
my only friend in this whole miserable
world ow
well dad was right I'll never ever never
never ever never be happy oh never never
say never huh no I'd look like a child
in this one
I need something elegant something
sophisticated you know a man's bib hot
lunch total honesty from a total babe
and who might you be
hmm and I will take one of everything
bibley things are gonna get messy
you
[Music]
[Music]
Nerys so good please give it up for your
minister of happiness your keeper of the
trolls me you scullery maid what's your
name
that's right a calm troll is a tasty
troll and you're a key ingredient in my
recipe for success
you see he who controls the trolls
controls the kingdom and I I am that he
by this time tomorrow I will be Queen
and all of Bergen town will get exactly
what they deserve true happiness oh if
only sire I've been out in the
wilderness thinking of nothing but how I
let you down if only there was some way
I could make you feel better I have
chosen an extra-special troll just for
you the happiest most positive sweetest
roll of all and because every Prince
deserves a princess I give you the one
they call princess poppy
it is hard time our hearts are
synchronizing why don't you try some
positivity a little positivity might go
with that vest
comb your it dude I knew it I knew it I
knew it
Shh so you guys want to stay quiet but
it's one of these yes yes yes oh good
good
let it out Bridget cry get it out good
just cry it's okay cry let it out good
I'm gonna be a very very mellow edgy
little poke out even further than her
with that that's great I think the King
really likes us is you could not sell us
out
Oh take him home yeah oh you could not
sell us out enjoy every second James
Walker I was good at it what was it guys
guys great man when you look in the
mirror let it disappear all your
insecurities when you look in the mirror
let it disappear all your insecurities
you're a dude
I knew it I knew it the whole time the
craziest party if I think the King
really likes us who I think the King
really likes us that's not like a keeper
the craziest party ever
are you sure you won't invite branch to
your party the craziest party ever
I think the key really likes us I mean
who even won't
Kate dipping coffee kicking hater coming
to your coronation
it's your big day I mean who even wants
that hater at your party I mean who even
wants that hater at your party
you
what it made you a new outfit I'm
thinking jumpsuit you always ruin
everything warning us about the bergen's
a vest with no shirt super cool I
remember that yeah that's our line one
two three super cool you always ruin
everything warning us about the Bergin's
[Laughter]
if you see that's right fitted as I say
I just let it all out
that's right Bridget just let it all out
a vest with no shirt super cool okay
dude that my for hide I'm warning us
about the Bergin's with no shirt super
cool hi time that's right Bridget just
let it all out what if we made Jen you
outfit hmm I'm thinking Joe - that's
super cool like really that's silver
bowl like dragging it out beautiful what
else I'm relaxed it let's try you like
that super cool let's try that super
cool that's super cool that is super
cool
all those things I shipped into but you
dance dance dance
when you dance dance dance feel the
good-good creeping up on you so just
dance dance dance come on I can't start
to fill it up I can start the feeling
I can start the bear Thank You Bridget
Bridget thank you thank you for not
eating us Bridget
you didn't eat us Thank You Bridget
dinner
ditto eat my glitter he's gaining on us
he's gaining on us
he's gaining well I guess we're all
gonna die oh boy here we go again
huh time I can squeeze you forever
don't forget the party favors party
favors
eat glitter
daddy you go when we move where you
already know
the struggle is real
the struggle is real the struggle is
real the struggle is real
oh my god the struggle is real the
struggle is real Yolo Yolo Yolo
you